[music]
>> Hey everybody.
My name is Philip Walton. And today I
want to start off by showing you a
screen recording that I made of two
different demos.
Both of these demos look and function
identically.
Both have drop-down menus that smoothly
animate in and out.
They're both fully keyboard accessible.
They both support light dismiss.
And they both work in Chrome, Firefox,
and Safari.
These demos were both also generated
using AI. In fact, they were generated
using the same coding agent, the same
model, and the same prompt.
The difference, though, is the version
on the left was generated using an agent
in its standard, default, out-of-the-box
configuration. And the version on the
right was generated using the same
agent, but with one extra thing
installed. And I'll get to that later.
But there is one more big difference
between these two demos.
If I open up DevTools and I zoom in here
on the network panel, you can see that
the version on the left loads 172 KB,
most of which is JavaScript, whereas the
one on the right loads less than 3 K and
uses absolutely no JavaScript.
And to be clear, that's 172 KB
over the wire, minified and gzipped,
with all of the production optimizations
turned on. And I didn't modify this code
at all. This is what the AI suggested.
Now, admittedly, this is a bit of a
contrived example because no app is just
a settings menu and nothing else. Once
you add more features, you might need to
add some more JavaScript. Still, I do
think this raises an interesting
question.
Why are AI coding agents recommending a
solution that requires almost 172 KB of
JavaScript when the same exact solution
can be built in a way that requires no
JavaScript at all and still works across
browsers?
So, if you were at any of the talks
earlier today, you heard a lot about
this. A lot about how amazing AI is. And
don't get me wrong, AI is amazing. Like,
it truly blows my mind every single day.
But, that is just one side of the story.
The truth is that while AI has
transformed the software industry, and
it has enabled us developers to write
code way faster than ever before,
there is another side of the story. AI
is definitely not perfect. And if you,
like me, follow a lot of well-known
front-end developers on social media,
then you'll know that many of these
folks are definitely not shy about
pointing out just how not perfect these
AI coding agents are.
Especially when it comes to writing HTML
and CSS.
And you know, these folks, they're not
wrong.
There have been so many amazing
developments on the web over the past
few years, and yet, if you ask a coding
agent to go build something for you on
the web, it's most likely not going to
reach for the latest web platform
features to do it. Even if those
features really are the best tool for
the job.
And this isn't all that surprising if
you consider that most of the training
data used by these models was written
during a time when most developers had
to support legacy browsers like Internet
Explorer.
But, regardless of the reason, the
reality is that for front-end web
development, coding agents do tend to
recommend legacy solutions, even when
there are better, more modern
alternatives.
Another big problem we see with AI
models is that they have a knowledge
gap. Every model has a knowledge cutoff
date, where any new developments on the
web that occurred after that date are
just not included in the model's
training.
In the past year alone, Chrome has
shipped more than 50 brand new web
features, but due to these knowledge
cutoffs, many of these features are just
completely unknown to these models.
And while techniques like rag and web
search can help with this problem, they
don't eliminate it entirely.
You know, if you ask a coding agent to
use a feature that it's never heard of,
it'll usually do a web search.
But, if you ask it to do something that
it thinks it already knows how to do,
then it'll often just reply confidently
right away without checking for more
up-to-date information.
For example, here's some code that an
agent uh generated after I asked it to
build a tool tip using the new interest
invokers API.
If you look closely at the highlighted
line of code, you can see that the model
used the interest target attribute,
which is not correct.
Interest target was the attribute name
when this API was first proposed back in
2023,
but right before the API shipped in
Chrome last fall, the name was changed
to interest for.
And so, that means that the code you see
on the screen will silently fail when
run in a browser, which will make it
pretty hard to debug.
Now, this specific problem is probably
going to be fixed for this API in the
next generation of the models, but the
larger problem is not going away anytime
soon.
A third problem we see is how AI models
make cross-browser support decisions. In
our testing, AI is way more conservative
than it needs to be when it comes to
cross-browser support.
It's understandable that these models or
these tool makers would want to optimize
for broad compatibility,
but now that we have initiatives like
Baseline, which includes compatibility
data for for nearly every web feature,
there's really no excuse for not using
it.
Agents should not be making generic
one-size-fits-all browser support
recommendations. They should be
tailoring their recommendations to the
specific needs of your project.
So, that's a quick overview of the main
problems we see with AI coding agents
when it comes to modern web development.
To recap,
AI coding agents frequently recommend
legacy patterns even though better, more
modern alternatives exist.
Second, AI models have blind spots and
either aren't aware of or have incorrect
information about the latest web
platform features. And third, AI models
tend to make outdated, one-size-fits-all
browser support recommendations.
But, the good news is that here in
Chrome, we believe that these problems
are all very solvable. And we've been
hard at work on a solution that we're
excited to share with you all today, an
early preview. We call it modern web
guidance.
Modern web guidance is a comprehensive
and expert-vetted set of skills covering
all of Chrome's best practices on
building for the modern web.
This package embeds decades of Chrome's
web platform experience expertise
directly into your coding agents.
And because it's based on skills, it
works with any AI coding platform.
You can install modern web guidance with
this single command.
NPX modern web guidance install.
Or if you're using any of the IDEs or
coding agents shown here on the screen,
you can find and install modern web
guidance directly from within these
tools.
So,
I know right now the market is
absolutely flooded with new skills
releases. And as a developer, it can be
challenging to keep up, overwhelming
even.
It's also especially hard to determine
which skills are good and worth using,
and which skills are, let's face it,
basically just slop.
So, I want to stress here that modern
web guidance is not your ordinary skills
pack.
This is something that we on the Chrome
team have been investing in a ton over
the past 6 months, and it's something
that we're committed to investing in for
the long term.
So, let's dive in and take a closer look
at what's included and how it works.
So, modern web guidance is comprised of
two distinct levels of guidance.
First, we have a set of high-level
guides codifying the best practices for
broad web disciplines like performance,
accessibility, security, user
experience, and many more.
In addition to these high-level guides,
we also have a set of very specific
low-level guides covering web features
that have been recently added to the
platform. And we're we've seen that AI
models just don't yet have a good
understanding of how to use them
properly.
All of these guides have been created by
members of the Chrome team in
collaboration with a number of external
subject matter experts that we've hired
to contribute to this project.
And because these guides focus on core
web platform features,
they will work regardless of whether
like whatever framework or stack you're
using or anything like that.
Now, before I dig deeper into the
specifics of these guides, I want to
give you all a quick over-overview of
how the tool works at a high level.
So, when you're using a coding agent out
of the box, the flow is pretty simple.
The user types a prompt into the tool,
the prompt is given to the AI model,
which then produces an output response.
If you're using modern web guidance,
then before the AI produces an output,
it'll perform a semantic search locally
within the modern web guidance package
to see if any of our guides match the
use case in the prompt.
If there are no matches, then those
guides will get added to the context
window.
And if there Sorry, if if there are
matches, those guides will get added to
the context window. If there are no
matches, the AI will respond as normal.
And then note that this is a bit
different from how most skills work,
where each skill is a distinct skill.md
file.
With modern web guidance, we expose a
single entry point scale that has access
to a CLI that does the search.
And we do this because we currently have
more than 100 distinct guides, and we
plan to add likely hundreds more.
So, it just doesn't scale to expose
these all as single top-level skill.md
files.
So, let's take a closer look at what
these guides look like.
Now, I mentioned before that we have
both high-level discipline skills and
low-level feature guides. The high-level
guides are very similar to the skills
that you've probably seen before, but
for the low-level feature guides, we
took a different approach that I think
is pretty novel, and so I want to talk
about it.
First, rather than focusing on the
features themselves we and documenting
how those features work, instead each of
these guides focuses on a distinct use
case that one of these features unlocks
or makes easier to implement.
For example, one of the use cases that
we identified for the view transitions
API has been unlocked was
visually connect persisting elements
across different page states or
navigations by smoothly morphing their
size, position, or other styling
properties.
For example, ex- expanding a thumbnail
image in a product list view into a full
bleed hero image in a product details
view.
Now, you'll notice that that use case
doesn't mention the view transition API
at all.
Instead, it describes a task that the
developer might want to implement or to
accomplish where the view transition API
happens to be the best choice to
implement it with. And this is really
important because developers don't
generally prompt their coding agents to
use specific features.
They might not even know that those
features exist.
Instead, they prompt their tools to
implement use cases and so we need our
guides to match the use the match the
prompts that developers are actually
using.
So, the second aspect of each of these
guides is that they're optimized for AI
consumption.
And by that, I mean that each guide is
concise, it gets straight to the point,
and it contains only the minimum amount
of information needed for the AI to
properly follow it.
This is more token efficient than doing
web search because even if the agent
finds up-to-date and accurate
information on the web,
which is not guaranteed, it still has to
read through all of that content, use
all of those tokens just to find the
bits that are relevant to your use case.
Or perhaps not, it might not find it.
Our guides are already scoped to the use
case, they're already vetted and tested
for accuracy, and they're already
locally on your device.
So, third, every guide
we include a section that documents our
specific recommendations and fallback
strategies to ensure that the
implementation of the use case works
across browsers.
Now, I want to dig into that last part
because this cross-browser fallback
guidance is, in my opinion, the absolute
best feature of this tool. So, let me
explain how it works.
For each guide, we start by documenting
the ideal implementation using the most
modern solution available.
For this part of the guide, we do not
take browser support into consideration
at all. We assume that any feature can
be used and we pick the best feature for
the task at hand. And we do this because
we want to support people who are
experimenting with new features, people
who are building extensions, Electron
apps, building internal company tools,
or really any situation where
cross-browser support is not a major
concern. We don't want AI tools to
prevent people from using new APIs if
their situation allows for it.
However,
if any of the features in the ideal
implementation are not baseline widely
available, then we always include a
fallback recommendation. And whenever
possible, we make sure that fallback
recommendation works across browsers.
The only exception to this is things
like
WebMCP, where there really is no
cross-browser fallback. But, in all
other cases, if there is a cross-browser
fallback, we use it. And if there's not,
we make it crystal clear that the
feature is only available in some
browsers and we show how to properly
feature detect for it.
And the reason we take this two-layered
approach, starting with the fully modern
and then going with the fallbacks, is so
that the agent can kind of pick and
choose how to implement the use case
based on your site's browser support
requirements.
And that brings me to the final feature
I want to talk about in this package,
our baseline integration.
I said that we want coding agents to be
able to customize the implementation
based on your browser support
requirements. And for this to work, two
things need to happen.
First, you need to tell your agent what
baseline target or browsers you support.
Agents can sometimes guess or infer this
information from various config files in
your project, but we think it's better
to be explicit and we recommend putting
this information directly into your
agents.md file.
If you don't declare any specific
browser support information, then the
agent will assume baseline widely
available.
Second,
in the fallback section of each of our
guides, we include detailed browser
compat data so that the agent can then
determine whether or not it needs to use
a particular fallback based on the
browser support requirements that you
put in your agents.md file.
For example,
if you're building an Electron app and
you set in your agents.md file that you
only need to support Chrome 144 and
newer,
then if the agent encounters a fallback
for something like say scroll-driven
animations, which shipped in Chrome 115,
then the agent can ignore that
recommendation and just stick with the
modern implementation.
This allows the agent to custom tailor
each guide's implementation to the
specific browser support requirements of
your project, rather than always having
to take a lowest common denominator
approach.
So, that's a quick overview of modern
web guidance and I assume at this point
many of you are probably thinking,
"Sounds great, but how well does it
actually work in practice?"
So, I do have some demos that I'm going
to show, so you will get to see it
working. Uh but before I show those, I
do want to address this question
directly because I think it's an
important one. I think it's important
that we, as an industry, are able to
evaluate the effectiveness of the skills
that we're using.
When we started this project,
one of the main requirements we had was
to ensure that we had rigorous evals for
every single feature that we used.
As of now, our eval suite includes 554
distinct assertions covering most of our
guidance, and we plan to expand that to
full coverage before our stable launch
later this year.
And we run this full eval suite every
single day against many of the popular
AI coding models, which right now
includes Gemini 3.1, Claude Opus 4.7,
and GPT 5.5.
Here on the screen, you can see a
visualization of the aggregate results
of all of these evals across all of
these coding models.
The number in green on the right shows
the average pass rate of eval assertions
for agents running with modern web
guidance installed. And the number on
the left shows the average pass rate for
the exact same set of assertions, but
this time from agents running without
modern web guidance installed. And we
call this the guided versus unguided
pass rate. So, as you can see,
the guided pass rate the guided agent
performs meaningfully and noticeably
better than the unguided agent.
It's not yet at 100%, but we're actively
fine-tuning both our guides and our
evals, because we want this number to be
as high as it can be.
So, what do these individual evals look
like?
Well, they're effectively prompts that
we give an agent, followed by a set of
assertions or tests that we run against
the agent's output.
Here's an example of a recent eval from
our scroll progress indicator use case.
We run the prompt that you can see on
the screen, along with the following
assertions, to test compliance with the
guides.
For this use case, the test checks to
see that the implementation correctly
uses scroll-driven animations, rather
than relying on scroll event listeners.
As you can see, with this particular
instance for this particular run, with
our guidance, all of the tests passed,
and without our guidance, all of them
failed.
So, this is a snapshot of how these
models are performing right now, but
it's not hard to imagine this changing
in the future.
At some point, as the models improve and
as the browser landscape changes, we
fully expect that many of these evals
will start passing even without our
guidance.
So, I mentioned that we run these evals
daily. Our plan here is to watch this
closely, monitor the results, and then
remove use case use cases once we start
noticing that the unguided version uh is
consistently performing as well as the
guided version in all of the popular
models. This will allow us to keep the
pack small, token efficient, and focus
just on the features that are not new or
that are new and not well known um by
the models and not covered in the
training.
But also keep in mind the new features
are shipping in browsers every single
month
and not knowledge cutoffs continue to
lag far behind. So, we believe this type
of guidance is going to continue to be
necessary long into the future.
And speaking of the future, I now want
to talk a bit about how we see this
project evolving over time.
For this early preview, we're launching
with about a dozen high-level discipline
guides
and more than 100 detailed use case
guides.
But we're definitely not going to stop
there.
Our plan is to continue adding more
guides to give us better coverage of the
existing web platform, but we're also
going to be covering new features as
they land.
In fact, our goal with this tool is to
ensure that every single new web
platform feature that ships in Chrome is
covered by this tool by the time it
lands in Chrome stable.
If you take a look at chromestatus.com,
you'll see that Chrome releases a lot of
new features every single milestone. So,
this is definitely an ambitious goal,
but it's one that we think is critical
to support the ongoing health and
success of the web in this new agentic
world.
We're also currently engaging with other
browser vendors to try to get coverage
for the features they're shipping as
well.
Okay, so to recap what I've covered
today. First, AI models have a knowledge
gap and blind spots. They recommend
legacy solutions even when there are
newer and better alternatives.
Second, modern web guidance fills those
knowledge gaps with vetted
recommendations from Chrome experts.
This helps ensure coding agents have a
full and complete understanding of the
modern web platform with clear
instructions on how to implement those
features in a way that is compatible
across browsers.
And third, Chrome is committed to
keeping modern web guidance up to date
as the platform evolves so that agentic
coding will always be at the forefront
of modern development modern web
development rather than constantly
lagging behind.
And with that,
who wants to see some demos?
Demos?
All right.
Uh I don't know if you guys can hear
that my Sorry about that, my phone was
going off. I was supposed to pick my son
up from preschool right now, I guess.
Uh hopefully my wife's doing that. Um
All right, here we are.
So, I want to start here on this phone.
I want to show you all an app that I'm
building.
Now,
I don't know if it's not
How's the focus?
Can you read it?
Okay, this monitor is a little weird.
Okay.
So, this is like an email application.
Uh it doesn't really matter what the
application is. I'm I'm building I'm
doing a project here where I want to
build I want to build a mobile website.
And my goal here is to make the mobile
website
function when I'm using it on my phone
as smoothly and polished and seamless as
the native applications that I use on my
phone.
I think as an industry like mobile first
came out 15 years ago and we got really
good at building
you know, building interfaces that look
good on a mobile screen size, but we
haven't really got good at building
interfaces that feel good on a mobile
screen size. So, that's my goal with
this.
And so, I was prompting Gemini. I was
using Antigravity and I asked it to
build something that looks similar to
Gmail.
Uh and it did this.
And then I said, "Okay, build me a
sidebar navigation drawer with a
hamburger menu and when I click the
hamburger menu, I want it to slide out."
So,
it does that. And you know, it looks
okay. It it kind of had all the links
that I wanted, but there's one thing one
thing here that's missing and you might
be able to guess what it is. When I put
my thumb here
and try to slide it close,
it's not working.
Now, I assume everyone has experienced
this at some point. You go to a mobile
website, you try to slide the navigation
drawer close, it doesn't work.
Literally every single native
application supports this functionality,
pretty much no no websites do.
And so, I want to change that.
And, you know, like the AI wasn't really
helping me here. I I I I I I asked it to
do this, and, you know, and I could keep
prompting, but I I wanted it to do that
by default. So, let's talk about how we
could fix this using modern web
guidance.
So, let's switch switch over to my uh
laptop.
I have Antigravity here,
and I want to
I want to talk through how I'm going to
approach doing this, but I want to do
something a little bit different.
I have actually two versions of
Antigravity running. I have this
Antigravity in light mode. My editor's
in light mode, that's how you tell the
difference.
And then,
hold on.
And then this is Antigravity running in
dark mode. If you look here on the
right, it says unguided.
And then when I switch back, it says
guided. So, I have two branches off a
single branch
with the exact same code base,
and I'm running two versions of
Antigravity.
One I'm going to say is guided, and one
is unguided. So, here in the guided
version,
let's go ahead and load up the terminal.
Uh I got it running, but
I'm going to install
modern web guidance.
And so, you can see I'm just running the
command NPX modern web guidance install.
And it's going to go through the flow.
Let me expand this so you can see it.
It's going to install it. I'm just going
to go ahead and click the default
recommendations. I'm going to do it in
my project.
Uh proceed with installation.
And so, if you look over here, and
actually let me go ahead and
uh rerun the dev server.
Okay.
So, if you look over here, it added this
dot agents folder. Look in my project.
If you use skills, you're used to this
flow.
Uh and then if I open this up, you can
see modern web guidance is installed
here
in the guided one and then if I switch
back to the unguided there's no skills.
So that's where we're starting. I also
have
two browser windows open, one in dark
mode. This is the unguided version
running its local dev server and this is
the guided version running its local dev
server.
They're both like I said, they're both
started from the same exact branch. I
can open up the sidebar and I'm trying
to swipe it close here. You can see it's
like dragging behind but the the sidebar
is not closing. So let's fix this.
I have some prompts prepared so you
don't have to watch me typing.
And let's go back into Integriti. I'm
going to start with the unguided
version. Oh, I'll also mention
uh
I had a
they updated all of our Integritis
today. Obviously, you probably heard the
announcement. So I'm going to try doing
this with Gemini 3.5 flash.
Never tried that before.
Hopefully it will work. If it doesn't
work, we'll go back to 3.1 but you know,
I want to try it. We'll see if it works.
So I'm going to paste this in. I'm going
to do it here and then I'm going to
switch back to the guided version and
then I'll read the prompt. So I say the
navigation drawer in this app looks fine
but I don't like that it can't swipe to
close it. Can you fix that?
So we can see here what it's doing. I'm
going to go ahead and close this
sidebar.
I'm going to zoom this over so we can
kind of watch what's happening.
So if you look up at the top, it is
running NPX, you know, minor web
guidance is doing a search command and
which is what I mentioned. It's
searching through the guide database. It
found a guide. It looks like it found a
guide kind of move this over. Found a
guide called navigation drawer.
And so it's it's starting to implement
that.
And then if we go back and look at the
unguided version
uh it's doing some things. Looks like
this is already done.
I'm going to go ahead and accept these
changes.
Uh let's go back to guided version. Is
that done?
Looks like it's almost done cuz it's
running the NPX build. Okay, look, that
one's done as well.
This is why I decided to do uh flash cuz
it is quite fast. So
I didn't want you all to have to sit
here and watch this running. So, here we
are in the unguided version.
Now, this is an AI demo, so this is very
risky. I don't know what's going to
happen. So, bear with me in case this
totally fails. I'm going to click the
hamburger menu and see what happens.
Okay, now I'm going to try to close it
with a swipe.
Okay, so it did it did swipe to close.
You probably couldn't pick up on what
was happening cuz you don't see like you
didn't feel what I was doing. Let me Let
me do this again cuz it something felt
weird about this.
I am dragging here. I don't know if you
can see behind. I'm dragging this. Okay,
there it closed.
I didn't pick my finger up. I put my
finger down. I was dragging
and then I didn't pick my finger up and
it closed. So,
I've done this demo a couple times. It
seems like Flash is doing a similar
thing. What I'm pretty sure is happening
here is that it is trying to detect the
swipe gesture and then it is calling a
close function. But I what I wanted to
do is I want it to literally like pin
the sheet to my finger as I'm moving it.
This is what I would expect.
And you know, so again, it it kind of
works, but
it it it doesn't it's it's definitely
better than without it, but it doesn't
it's not quite what I want. So, let's go
back to the guided version and let's see
how it did.
Fingers crossed.
Okay, it opens up.
I'm going to click. I'm going to drag.
Click and drag.
>> [applause]
>> And so, you might even notice here the
backdrop is fading ever so slightly as
I'm dragging.
And this uh
cuz I know which guide it used, this is
using scroll driven animation to do that
backdrop fade and it's it's tracking
with the scroll gesture.
This the the the dragging here is being
handled using scroll snap points. So,
it's actually a scroll interface, which
means it uses the browser's default
physics and all of the hardware
acceleration of scrolling.
So, I can swipe it to close and you
know, I can swipe it like that and that
looks great.
Okay, but you know, we got to do some
more features, so let's keep moving.
All right, I'm going to add this, copy
this next prompt. Let's go to the
unguided version,
paste it in,
and then go to the guided version, paste
it in, and then I'll read what the
prompt is.
Okay, so the prompt is, "Now add a
message view drill down so that when I
click an email link in the inbox, it
drills down into the full email message
view
with a back button so that I can return
to the inbox view. The message should
also have standard email action buttons
like archive, reply, star, etc. But
don't hook those up yet, just get the
back button working."
All right, so Modern Web Guidance is
doing its thing.
It's looking for some guides.
Um
let's go back and see what's the
unguided version is doing. Okay, it's
still working as well.
And so, I can see here that Modern Web
Guidance is retrieving a guide called
stack drill down. This is just the idea
of the use case that it's retrieving.
And if we're if we have some time, I can
If it's not going to finish yet. Okay,
looks like this one finished.
Um I might show the guides if we if we
have some time, but since this finished,
I'm going to go back and I'm going to
check the unguided version to see what
happens. So, I'm going to click an email
message in the inbox view,
and I want it to show me the full
message.
Okay, so show me the full message.
Uh it didn't animate or transition in.
Like I mentioned, I want this to feel
like a native application.
Does the back button work? Okay, the
back button works. So, this is kind of a
harsh transition.
Um
so, let's see if the other one is done.
And let's see
Okay, it looks like it says, "I've
successfully integrated the stack drill
down transition module into the main
Okay, like it did it. It's using some,
you know, of the kind of describes here
what it's doing.
Now, let's go and check to see
what it looks like.
Again, fingers crossed.
Okay, so it worked. It smoothly
transitioned in. I can click the back
back button and it transitioned out.
Now, let's see if I can
swipe to go backwards.
Okay, I can swipe to go backwards.
That's nice.
>> [applause]
>> I'm also noticing a little bit of
parallax going on here as I'm swiping
it.
Which is also driven using scroll driven
or done using scroll driven animations.
And and actually I'm looking at the
I'm looking up here in the navigation
bar
and I see that when I click, it does
updates the history.
And then let's see if I click the back
button.
Swipes back.
Like okay, like I didn't have to know
how any of this stuff worked. I just
typed it into the prompt.
Let's do one more thing. Let's just try
to get a little bit of a cherry on top
situation here.
All right, let's go into the un Let me
go back and accept these changes for
now. Okay, go back into the unguided
version and then again the guided
version.
All right, in the inbox view, make it so
that I can quickly archive or snooze
messages by swiping them left or right
without having to open each one
individually.
So, I don't know if you guys are like
me, you have your email app, you get a
lot of email that you don't care about.
I spend most of my time in my email app
just going like this. Swiping and
swiping and swiping all of the unread
emails or, you know, that way. I don't
want to have to click into each of them
individually.
So,
okay, it says this one is done also. Is
this one done? Okay, this one's still
working. So, let's go check and see what
the unguided version did.
Okay, it's
So, it's it's doing the same thing it
did before where it's not pinned to my
finger. It's not dragging with my
finger, but it is detecting a swipe
gesture.
And okay, looks like it does support
both.
I'll be honest, I've done this demo a
bunch. This is maybe the best the
unguided has ever done.
>> [laughter]
>> But it's still not it's still not
exactly what I want.
Uh okay, let's see if the other one is
done. Switching back to the guided
version. Okay, looks like it is done.
All right. Uh and let's check how that
one did.
Okay, much better. This is I mean this
is kind of looks
very similar to how Gmail looks.
I can swipe it from that side, swipe
them all closed.
I can
snooze it from this side.
So, this is great. But this is the kind
of thing that
you really can't know like you watching
me do this, you don't really know how it
is. But I think if we switch back to the
phone, I want to pull this up on my
phone, and I want you to watch me doing
it on the phone just get the full
effect.
Okay, so let's see we
click the side Oh, you can Hold on,
let's see.
There's that reflection. Okay, so I can
swipe this closed.
And this is the kind of thing where if I
put it like halfway and I let go, it
swipes back. If I do it more than
halfway and let go, sorry, I wasn't
quite more than halfway.
It's a little bit hard for me to see cuz
it's reflecting my face.
>> [laughter]
>> But yeah, so with scroll snap, the way
that it works is is kind of the same way
that the native browser the native like
app physics work, where if you do it
more than halfway, it'll it'll finish it
like snap to a snap point. Which is
great. If I click on a message,
you know, I can click on any of these
messages,
and then I think so it should work as
well like if I do the back gesture.
Not very good at this. Okay, there we
go. The back gesture on Pixel.
And then if I, you know,
swipe through the emails,
you know, snooze.
The whole thing feels really nice. Like
it feels really nice and smooth to me.
And and just to show that what I said
earlier is not a lie,
I have an iPhone right here.
Refresh.
Do the same thing.
Swipe.
Click into a
you know, click into a message.
The whole parallax thing.
Sorry, trying to get this so you don't
see the reflection.
It all feels very smooth. It feels like
I can't tell this is not a native app
that I'm using it other than seeing the
address bar down here at the bottom.
>> [applause]
>> Let's switch back to the slides.
Oops.
We pressed at the same time. All right.
So,
to wrap up,
in Chrome we care deeply about the
health of the open web,
and we invest a ton into improving the
platform so that developers can build
better experiences and so the businesses
can be the so businesses that are built
on the web can ultimately be more
successful.
But the truth is that improving just the
web platform, it's not good enough.
We have to actually improve the web.
Because users don't visit the web
platform,
they visit the web as it exists today
on the websites that they actually
visit. So, if we want to make the web
better, then at the end of the day,
we're going to actually have to make it
as easy as possible for you developers
to use all of these amazing features
that Chrome is adding to the platform.
And that's why we built modern web
guidance.
But also, that's why we want to hear
from you all.
We want to make sure that this tool
works for you and that it helps you
build better experiences. So, we'd love
for everyone to try out this early
preview and give us feedback. If you're
running into problems,
or if there are use cases that you feel
are missing, then definitely let us
know.
The link on the screen here will take
you to a site with information on how
you can contribute contribute and give
feedback. And with that, thank you all
very much.
>> [applause and music]